♪
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT NOW AS
SENATE LAWMAKERS GRILL THE
AG NOMINEE WILLIAM BARR, WE
ARE LEARNING MORE ABOUT THE
DEEP STATE AND THE ABUSES HE
WILL BE COB FRONTING WHEN
CONFIRMED.
FOR EXAMPLE, ACCORDING TO
REPORTING FROM OUR OWN
CATHERINE HERRIDGE, FORMER
TOP FBI LAWYER JAMES BAKER,
THIS IS UNDER COMEY, IS THE
SUBJECT NOW OF A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION INTO ILLEGAL
LEAKS TO THE MEDIA.
THIS ALSO GROWING EVIDENCE
OF THE DEEP ANTI-TRUMP BIAS
AMONG SENIOR FBI OFFICIALS.
NOW, WITH DEVIN NUNES FROM
THE HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE
REVEALING THAT THE BUREAU'S
LEADERS, GOAT:  HAD NO REAL
EVIDENCE AGAINST THE TRUMP
TEAM BUT LAUNCHED AN
INVESTIGATION ANYWAY
FOLLOWING THE COMEY FIRING.
JOINING US NOW FOR REACTION
IS THE CONGRESSMAN HIMSELF
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES,
WHEN I HEAR THAT, WHAT I'M
HEARING IS THAT IS A REVENGE
INVESTIGATION BUT IT HAD
ALREADY GONE ON FOR NINE
MONTHS.
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THEY
EXONERATE YOU HAD HILLARY,
WITH NO INVESTIGATION, THEY
LAUNCHED THE SO-CALLED
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION
INVESTIGATION.
NINE MONTHS INTO IT, COMEY
IS FIRED.
BUT WE LEARN FROM PETER
STRZOK, LARGER HIMSELF AND
COMEY THAT THEY HAD NOTHING
AT THAT POINT.
>> WHY WOULD THEY SUBMIT A
ROOM PRESIDENT CONSPIRED
WITH PUTIN TO FIRE COMEY.
>> SEAN, LET'S THINK ABOUT
IT A DIFFERENT WAY.
WE HAVE THESE SUPPOSED
RICKENBACKER HAWKS SITTING
OVER AT THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE DIVISION
AT THE FBI AND DOJ.
WHERE WERE THEY IN 2012 WHEN
BARACK OBAMA GOT CAUGHT ON A
HOT MIKE TELLING THE RUSSIAN
LEADER AT THE TIME HE NEEDED
TO MORE TIME TO RATE UNTIL
AFTER THE ELECTION?
IT LOOKS LIKE THAT WAS
TRYING TO WORK WITH
RUSSIANS.
WHERE WERE THEY
INVESTIGATING WHEN THE
UKRAINIANS WERE BEGGING THE
UNITED STATES FOR WEAPONS IN
THE CONGRESS WAS TRYING TO
GIVE WEAPONS TO THE
UKRAINIANS AFTER THE
RUSSIANS HAD INVADED AND
ANNEXED CRIMEA, NOBODY WENT
TO INVESTIGATE THE OBAMA
WHITE HOUSE OR PRESIDENT
OBAMA.
SO, YOU HAVE NO EVIDENCE IN
THIS CASE.
YOU HAVE NO RECORDS, NO
PHONE CALLS, ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING OF ANY SORT AND,
YET, YOU SUPPOSEDLY
REPORTEDLY ARE INVESTIGATION
THE PRESIDENT?
AND FURTHERMORE SUPPOSEDLY
THIS SCOPE MEMO THAT
OUTLINES WHATEVER MUELLER IS
SUPPOSED TO BE LOOKING AT,
IF THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
STORY IS TO BE BELIEVED FROM
LAST FRIDAY NIGHT A FRIDAY
NIGHT NEWS DUMP, IF THAT'S
TO BE BELIEVED THEN THAT
MEANS SOMEBODY LEAKED PIECES
OF THAT SCOPE MEMO TO THE
"NEW YORK TIMES."
WE STILL HAVE YET TO SEE IT
HERE IN THE CONGRESS.
>> Sean: JOHN UNIONER HAS
BEEN INVESTIGATING.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE
SEEN THIS HEED LINE IN THE
"NEW YORK TIMES."
MCCABE TRIES TO REENGAGE
CHRISTOPHER STEEL AFTER
COMEY WAS FIRED AND THEY
HAVE A TRANSCRIPT SUPPOSEDLY
BY BRUCE OHR SHOWING THE FBI
WENT BACK TO STEEL BETWEEN
COMEY'S FIRING AND MUELLER'S
APPOINTMENT.
NOW WE ALSO KNOW THAT THERE
WAS COMMUNICATION, BRUCE OHR
WAS THE CONDUIT, IF YOU
WILL, FOR CHRISTOPHER
STEELE.
AND HE WAS TRYING TO GET HIS
INFORMATION.
REMEMBER, THE DOSSIER HAS
BEEN DISCREDITED.
HE WAS FIRED.
STILL IN CONTACT WITH ALL
THESE TOP OFFICIALS AND
TRYING TO FEED INFORMATION
TO MUELLER WHICH WE GOT IN
THE EXCHANGES OF BRUCE OHR.
>> SO, REMEMBER HOW WE GOT
HERE.
WE SET UP A TASK FORCE.
WE GAVE A LIST TO AT THE END
OF THE LAST CONGRESS OR
ACTUALLY LAST SUMMER.
TASK FORCE WAS CREATED TO
CONDUCT A BUNCH OF ENTRIES
WHAT SUPPOSEDLY IS LEAKING
OUT ARE PIECES OF THESE
INTERVIEWS THAT CHAIRMAN GOD
I CAN'T UNDERSTAND CHAIRMAN
GOODLATTE HAD ASKED FOR THE
FBI AND DOJ TO RELEASE THEM.
THEY SAT ON THEM.
NOW I THINK WHAT'S HAPPENING
IS PEOPLE ARE SELECT TIALY
LEAKING PIECES OF THIS.
I HAVE RATIFIED THIS STORY A
NUMBER OF TIMES.
I HAVE KNOT READ THE
TRANSCRIPTS.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S TRUE
OR NOT BUT OBVIOUSLY IT'S
VERY ALARMING IF IT'S TRUE
THAT THINK WERE ALREADY
TRYING TO GET HIM TO GO BACK
TO STEELE AND GET HIM TO
COME BACK AFTER THEY PLAN TO
WAS NORMALITIED AND PHI LIE.
WE NEED TO KNOW MORE ABOUT
THIS WHICH IS WHY THESE
TRANSCRIPTS HAVE FROM ALL
THESE INTERVIEWS NEED TO BE
RELEASED.
>> Sean: WE HAVE GOT TO HOPE